それでびっくりして そのオウムに
私はもう助け求めてもう一つのところに行ったんだけど
そんな話じゃなくて すっごい凶暴な恐ろしい言葉を喋ってたんだと
あなたはものすごい丁寧にもう私に接待をしてるんだと
不思議だなと思ったら
そのオウムさんが あ そうですか
おそらくあれ私の兄弟だと思いますよと
兄弟だと思いますよと
なんでそう思います？それはまあ
本当は私たちはもう台風で木が折れて
もう巣がなくなって いわゆるみなしごになったところで
私は行者たちがもう買って育てたんだと
おそらく私の兄弟が森の中に隠れてる泥棒たちに育てられたでしょうと
だからそういう教育によって我々はまるっきり別人で別人になりましたよということで
オウムさん オウムが王様に教えてあげるんですね
だからそのストーリーもやっぱり
まあこれと全く似てます
あのスーパーマンの映画もね
まあスーパーマンの映画はもう全くインチキだらけですけど
こちらは一応あり得る
ですから体完全にイコールであろうとも
心の働きはまた別扱ってるんですね
ですからこの今この牛とか作ってるんですけど
あのDNA分裂させて同じね
何 クローン？クローン作ってますけど
たとえクローン作っても性格は似てるということはないというのは仏教の立場なんですね
でもまだ証拠がないんだから何とも言えません
仏教の立場から見れば
一応しっかりと やっぱり心は違うでしょうと DNA
じゃないんだと だから科学者が今クローン人間
クローン動物を作ることには反対賛成意見 2つありますけど
動物の場合はいいんだけど
あの人間の場合はやるなと
そんなやることやったら
ヒットラーみたいな恐ろしい人間作ったらどうなるんでしょうかとかね
そういうのはまたSF映画みたいな考え方なんですけどね
で かえって人間っていうのは
科学者とか政治家ほど汚い人間が世の中にないんだから
やっぱりやらないわけでもないんですね
まずやるのは悪いことだからね
まず作るのは原子爆弾だから
それから人に役に立つこともちょっとちょっと作る人々だから
政治家まず考えるのは人殺すことであって
それ無理だったら平和にしましょうと
できるならば殺すと 殺せない
じゃあ平和でいいよというふうな
このそこですごい平和主義になるんですけど
結局平和主義でもなんでもないんですね
だからそういう世の中の政治家見たら同じことでしょう
みんなまあ殺したいという気持ちは先にあるんですね
それはやばいと感じたら
まあ平和でいいんじゃないかというふうにもかっつけちゃう
ですから まあ恐ろしい人を作ろうといえば
そういうふうにやらないわけでもないんだけど
でも世の中で人間っていうのは
この生まれつき恐ろしい場合は
この体の欠陥がある時も恐ろしくなる
凶暴になる場合あるんですね
脳の異常があったりすると
そういう凶暴さっていうのは医学的だから
その人を捕まってどこかに鍵かけて置いておけば問題終わりでしょ
その人は人に説法して
みんなで大勢みんな来てくださいね
殺しましょうというふうにはなりませんね
でもみんなに話しかけて
みんな殺戮に呼びかけるのは健康的な人間なんです
精神的な病気な人にはそこまで能力はないんです
そこで MRA とか何とか取ってみたら
この異常すぐわかるし
それから脳の DNA ではなくてアミノ酸見たら見たら
あ これこのこのこの成分がちょっと違ってるんだとすぐわかるし
それに薬を投与して手術でも解決できます
ですから このたとえクローン人間を作っても心が違う
ですから 性格がまあ受け取った心の波動とそれからの教育によって変わるんだと
心は確実にもう影響によって変化するものなんです
一番影響を受けやすいのは心
体はかなり頑固で もう物体だからね
寒さに早くやられるのは心であって
体はそんな早くやられるわけじゃないんです
心が弱いんだったら もう息が心の息がなくなったら
もう寒さにはもう嫌だとかね
なっちゃうし 心は体はまあそんなにもう弱いわけじゃないんです
例えば人から何か聞いただけでいきなり怒ったりして
ムカついたりして 腹が立ったり
それ心でしょう 例えば人に殴られたとします
体は痛いんだけど 別にそれだけのことで
二 三分待っていればそれは治っちゃうでしょうに
かなり抵抗力を持ってるんです
心そうじゃないんです
すぐなんで殴ったんですかと怒るんですね
それをもう瞬時に問題を起こしちゃうんです
だからすっごい影響を受けやすいのは心
笑ってる人はもう怒ることはものすごい簡単にできるんです
そこで悪いところ 悪い方向の影響は受けやすいんですね
泣いてる人を笑わせるのは結構難しいんです
だから暗い人を明るくするのは難しいんですね
でも明るい人を暗くするのはとても簡単
それにも理由がありまして
どうせ心っていうのは貪瞋痴の衝動ですから
だから悪い方向には行きやすい
良い方向には行きにくい
そこで仏教ではまあそれは精進しましょうと
心の影響を受けやすい性格と精進ということと合体させて
心を良い方向へ持っていくことを教えているんですね
だから体のことを気にするなと
置いておきましょうと
それは無駄な努力ですからね
ただただの物体だからに
それは正しい教えであって
インチキの教えになっちゃうと
この瞑想すれば病気治りますよと言った方がずいぶんもう早く売れるんですね
このお祈りすればがんが治りますと
この特別なこのお経をやればもう商売繁盛できますと
と体のことを言うと もう人気爆発ですね
でもそれは完全に間違いであって
嘘の世界ですね だから仏教ではまあ私は病気だから何ですかと
じゃあ治してあげますよと言えない
だから何よと だから人が病気で困ってるんだったら
なんで困ってるんですかと
困るなと それだけ 困ってるのは心だから
あるいは仏教ではこの模範的な夫婦がいて
昔お釈迦様の時代で この十六歳で結婚して必ず
亡くなったんだけど ものすごい互いに信頼していた
無批判的なんですね その夫婦が過去生で何回も何回も
お釈迦様の両親でした
そこでお釈迦様がある日どこかへ旅に出た時は
ある日突然初めてこのおじいちゃんに出会ったんです
顔を合わせた瞬間に そのおじいさんがいきなり泣きながら
お釈迦様にもう息子と呼ぶんですね
なんであんたはもう久しぶりではないかと
お母さん待ってるよと
早く家へ行ってお母さんに顔を見せなさいよと
ただみんなこの人ちょっとおかしいんじゃないかとお釈迦様のお父さんというのは違うでしょうと
お釈迦様は何も言わないで
はい わかりましたと言って
もう家に行くんです そしたらお母さんもああ
お前 息子もよくもよくも来てくれたと
会いたくて会いたくて
もうもうもうたまらなかったとかなんとか泣きながら
で お釈迦様は自分の弟子たちにね
まあこういうのは この二人が昔も何回も何回も私の両親でいて
その愛情がね よみがえったと
私を見たところで だからそれはもうどうしようもないことだからね
お釈迦様は息子みたいな感じで説法したり
そこで仏教徒になってね
そのナクラという名前なんですけど
ある日お釈迦様に会って
こう言うんですね 私はもう体がすごく弱くて
ものすごく病気で どうしようもないんだと
年取るということほどの嫌なことは世の中にないんだと
もう先もないんだと でもそこまで死ぬまででも生きることは大変苦しいんだと
病気病弱でも でお釈迦様はじゃああなたを祝福して治しますと
そんなインチキはしなかったんですね
お釈迦様は確かにあなたの体はもうガタガタ状態で
あなたにとっては生きることは苦しみであるんだと
でも体がたとえ病気になっても
心は病気にならないようにしなさいと
教えたんですね だからお釈迦様は人をごまかしとかね
騙しとかは全然しません
体がたとえ病気になっても
心だけは病気にならないようにと
体はただの物体としての
物体として扱えばよろしいんですね
心さえ元気だったらもう体は頑張ってくれるんです
頑張ってくれるんだけど
細胞の法則はそれなりにありますから
年取ることはもう避けられません
どんどん我々は消えて消えているでしょう
だから今は生まれる細胞の数よりは死ぬ細胞の数が多いんです
だから体力はどんどんどんどん減退します
筋肉が衰えますしね 髪の毛が白くなるし
それは避けられません
だからといって別に心で病気になる必要はないんです
心には年というものはないんだからね
まあそういうことはアビダルマの話じゃなくて
ただの説法的な話ですからね
そこら辺で今日話を一つのポイントになりましたから
そこら辺終了したかっただけ
で 次にやるのはもう一つパッターナナという条件の説明
そこはちょっと難しいです
アプローチは随分違いますからね
それとつなげないようにしますということで
[背景音]